[Musique]
ça nous concerne parce que on a observé
lors des élections locales
départementales et régionales 2021 une
abstention extrêmement forte et donc un
éloignement des citoyens de nos
institutions et de du sens de l'utilité
du d'aller voter tout simplement la
culture citoyenne c'est ce que nous
avions à une certaine époque et que nous
avons laissé se déliter cette culture de
citoyenne nous permet de nous projeter
dans un avenir commun à me partage donc
des valeurs allaient constat de la
mission d'information sur l'enseignement
moral et civique
c'est d'abord une
dispersion si je peux dire dans cet
enseignement le programme sont
pléthoriques s'intéresse à des des tas
de sujets sociétaux qui sont certes
importants mais qui ne correspondent pas
aux objectifs premiers de l'om c'est
l'objectif premier c'est de centrer
l'enseignement sur la connaissance des
institutions le rôle des élus que ce
soit des élus locaux des parlementaires
à quelques niveaux que ce soit et donc
on considère qu'il faut vraiment
corriger cela avec une refonte des
programmes par exemple c'est avec de
bonnes fondations qu'on construit donc
un autre république et la fondation
c'est la collectivité locale d'après
donc les derniers sondages et depuis
déjà quelque temps les français font
avant tout confiance à leur maire et
c'est dans la ville dans le village que
doit se construire donc cette culture et
elle doit partir de là pour avoir de
bonnes fondations qui nous permettent de
nous projeter et c'est pour ça que nous
recommandons donc beaucoup
d'expérimentation et faire en sorte que
cette démocratie et que cette culture et
se rebaptise se réinvente haut niveau le
train
[Musique]